machine learning can be used to derive
insights from huge amounts of data in
our respective Fields especially if it's
something we can't just look up quickly
having computers that learn from our
examples and build recipes called models
helps us automate the process of finding
insights and with great accuracy
now ml isn't Magic it's designed to give
you results on the specific thing you
trained it on and nothing else
however let's be honest the traditional
path for learning ml can take you
hundreds of hours to ramp up on and
currently requires experimenting with
different algorithms via trial and error
until you find one that gives you the
results you like
and yet there is great urgency to
accelerate our work in meaningful areas
such as climate-based Solutions and so
in this episode we will dive a bit
deeper into how we use our favorite
generalist ml technique that we use in
this people on planet AI series
[Music]
out of the many ml algorithms out there
I'm happy to share that deep learning is
a technique that can be used for almost
any supervised learning job
in supervised learning you telecomputer
the right answers to look for through
examples
deep learning is very flexible and is a
great go-to algorithm
especially for images audio or video
files which are types of
multi-dimensional data
this is because each of these data types
have one or more Dimensions with
specific values for each point
more specifically images are a
collection of red green and blue
or RGB values across a 2d space
audio has a wave amplitude across time
video also has RGB values but across
space and time
for example training a model to classify
tree species from satellite images is a
kind of image segmentation problem which
is classifying every pixel in an image
however satellite sensors collect a
wider range of bands than the typical
images based on the three RGB channels
in contrast to traditional computer
science programming is kind of like a
glorified calculator
we may approach this problem by writing
a function with explicit and sequential
steps that review every single Pixel one
by one for every image
this is quite prone to errors which
makes it hard to maintain it also uses
loads of computing resources and hours
because of all of this it's also really
expensive
on top of this if you then wish to
modify the function to include another
type of tree species you may have to
rewrite your function altogether
this is where training an ml model via
deep learning can greatly simplify
things instead of hand crafting every
instruction you give image examples with
labels of tree species to the computer
and let it learn from them
and when you want to find more tree
species it's as simple as adding new
images and retraining the model
with that reference in mind let's dive a
bit deeper into how deep learning works
with a specific example
let's say you want to compare satellite
images in different years to see where
deforestation is happening in your
supply chain
note that a machine learning model is
like a function that takes input data
transforms it and returns to something
else such as the classification label of
where there is a tree or no tree or it
could also give us the magnitude of a
value like the density of tree canopy
which is known as regression
to begin we will need a data set that
includes satellite images that have
labels of where there are trees and
where there aren't
now machine learning only understands
tensors which are numbers stored as an
array or vector in one dimension or as a
matrix or table in two Dimensions or as
multi-dimensional data
with this in mind we convert satellite
images into tensors where each pixel has
one number for every satellite band
we have to frame our model differently
depending on our goal
here are a few common goals
regression which predicts a number
binary classification which makes a
prediction between two categories
multi-class classification which
classifies things across multiple
categories
semantic segmentation classifies every
pixel in an image and embeddings which
groups similar elements into a
multi-dimensional space
in our case we simply want to know if
there are trees or not for every pixel
so this would be a binary semantic
segmentation problem
we then expect the outputs to be the
probabilities of trees for every pixel
as a number between 0 and 1.
zero representing no trees and one
represents a high confidence entries
but how do we go from input images into
probabilities of trees
well think about it this way a model is
a collection of interconnected layers at
each layer data is transformed
and based on our desired output we must
come up with an arrangement of layers
that transform our input data into our
desired outputs
the first layer of ingesting data is
called the pre-processing or
normalization layer
this is because machine learning doesn't
like large numbers so we have to
transform input data into smaller
numbers at this first layer
after that there are many layers we can
choose from kind of like Legos these
dictate the model's architecture
here are the common ones
dense layers these interconnect all the
output from the previous layer to all
the inputs in the next layer
convolutional layers these look at the
surrounding patch of input values and
connect them to the next layer
deconvolutional layers these project the
value into a patch of values in the next
layer
pooling layers these aggregate values
into the next layer
each layer by the way has something
called an activation function which
transforms the outputs of each layer
before it passes them to the next layer
going back to our deforestation use case
in Supply chains after that first layer
of pre-processing and input image we
then add a 2d convolutional layer
followed by a deconvolutional layer
which gives us a total of three layers
so far
we could add more layers by the way but
this is a good starting point we then
reach the fourth and last layer
depending on our goals at the beginning
we choose an appropriate loss function
that helps us score how well the model
did during training
a larger loss for example means it has
room for improvement the model adjusts
to do better the next time it sees that
example
here's a handy dandy table by the way
with our recommended activation and loss
functions to choose from based on your
goal we hope this saves you time
for our use case because we use binary
semantic segmentation we choose to use a
dense layer with a single output at that
last layer
this helps classify every pixel in
satellite images with a value between 0
and 1.
we also choose a sigmoid activation
function and an IOU loss function
now that we have a model and have some
examples to teach it we are ready to
train our model
ideally we want to split our training
examples into two data sets one is for
the model to train on and learn from the
other validates how well the model did
on data it has never seen before
if the model does well with the training
data set by the way but now with the
validation data set it might be overfit
meaning that it memorized the training
examples
but providing it with more training data
or adding more layers could help
overall this was a super quick summary
to help demystify why we use neural
networks in our people and Planet AI
developer series
we also hope this inspires you to build
sustainability use cases with deep
learning
if you would like to review this process
in Greater detail I have Linked In the
description below a blog post and
several helpful resources
and Community if you found this content
helpful you can follow us further on
this journey cheers
foreign